north las vegas teen has died after
police say he took pills that may have
been laced with fentanyl the powerful
illicit opioid is 50 to 100 times more
potent than morphine victoria saha joins
us live with what police and parents say
happen in this case
we're told 15 year old jerriann morgan
collapsed here at sedway middle school
during soccer on wednesday and he died
later that night but what we're learning
today is that he was one of five
students who took those pills
jeremy morgan was rushed to dignity
health where he died but according to
police it was difficult to know exactly
how thursday morning north las vegas
police were contacted by clark county
school district police saying four other
students were rushed to the hospital
they later found out all five students
had taken pills that may have contained
fentanyl this is bizarre i'm at the
point where i want to pull my son from
school because i don't feel safe we
spoke to a mom of a student at sedway
she wanted to remain anonymous but says
her son saw a picture of the pills
posted by a peer on instagram wednesday
from my understanding is that one of the
children actually received it or stole
it i should say from a family member
officer alexander cuevas with north las
vegas police department could not
confirm or deny that he did say ccsd
police officers did recover all the
pills on school property thursday there
are about a dozen pills that could fit
into the palm of your hand similar to
how these look it's very dangerous very
potent it's something that no one
no unprofessional person should handle
and no one should handle in the general
public it is not clear exactly how
school police were able to find them as
for parents they say they're upset there
wasn't anything communicated to them
about the drugs found on property how
could somebody not notice the principal
sent out a letter to families informing
them about a student's death
the other four students who took those
pills are expected to be ok they
experienced nausea and vomiting now this
is an ongoing investigation police are
asking for anyone if you know any
information regarding this please
contact them reporting live tonight from
north las vegas victoria saha live local
now